hey everybody welcome back to the taste
of adventure dlc campaign in parkitect
today it's time for brimstone peak and
as you might be able to tell from these
weird
gear-shaped things on the side of this
floating island this is going to be a
steampunk themed map
now the description says that this
steampunk themed amusement park
straddling an active
straddle volcano struggles to attract
visitors due to its dangerous
environment
turn the situation around by expanding
this unique theme park into a hotspot
for thrill seekers
but let's hope that the volcano doesn't
erupt well spoiler alerts there are no
volcano
mechanics or anything like that i think
we'll probably be fine
but let's check out the park anyway and
see what we can do with it
this is gonna be an interesting one
because it's one of those parks that you
actually do start off with some rides
and also a little bit of scenery so as
you can tell we have a roller coaster
which is another
inverting spinning coaster with a launch
over here
and then also we have this combination
and anybody who's played roller coaster
tycoon
and remembers mouse world might
recognize this honestly
i was just inspired by mel's world to do
this this quick
drop tower and top spin combination uh
and quickly also let's do a pov of
caligula's wrath here
which is a kind of strange coaster
honestly
i just wanted to put this kind of
coaster in one of the maps just to show
off how cool i think the coaster type is
especially because this dlc does bring
quite a bit of new stuff
into the game i wanted to make use of
that as much as possible in the scenario
maps as well
so yeah it has this really crazy pretzel
kind of element at the start of the
layout and then it just kind of meanders
around the volcano
does a 0g roll here which would be so
interesting to experience on a spinning
coaster i think
it does take all of the elements a
little bit slowly and
you might look at this and think wait
isn't that way too slow
i'm not sure i think you do want your
spinning inverted coasters to be a
little bit slower than a typical
launched coaster because the spinning
already makes it more intense
but yeah altogether that's just what it
does
and that only occupies a small part of
the total map that we have here so as
you can see
lots of space to still play around with
and build terrain based roller coasters
and i think that's also going to be the
focus of this map
we also start off with the inverting
wooden coaster which we haven't seen so
far
but it's a really interesting type of
wooden coaster that can also do
inversions
and as soon as you do that it switches
to a fully steel track
this is a reference to the real-life gci
inverting wooden coaster although the
trains are more like a gravity group
i think mineblower is a very interesting
example of a coaster that you'd be able
to
pretty much exactly recreate in
parkitect using this type
and then we also have the suspended
coaster which is a classic of course
but i'm definitely gonna have to put one
of these woodies in
also we have a very steampunk-ish
collection of rides including the
clockwork which i also haven't placed
yet but this thing is so cool to watch
go around
i'll place this somewhere and and you'll
go you guys will have a look at it later
and then also some gentle rights not too
interesting but i do think the gentle
monorail ride is something i've never
ever used so it would be fun to see if i
can work that into this map especially
considering you know looking at the
theme here
the colors and the use of different
shapes and steampunky details
i think if it fits into any scenario map
it's definitely this one
so anyway without further ado let's get
to building
wait wait hold the phone i completely
forgot that i didn't cover the goals of
this scenario so let's quickly go over
them
the main goal is to get 800 guests into
the park we need to have a price
satisfaction rating of at least 75
that's fairly doable we need to have an
overall park rating of at least 85
percent
that's doable too but it's going to be a
bit harder
and the optional goals are where it gets
interesting
i know for sure during the base game
scenarios there were certain scenarios
with
non-optional goals that were kind of
optional anyway or the other way around
for the dlc it's it's all in order so
optional goals are completely optional
and
never goals on the way to the main goal
or anything like this
but they also added some extra
challenges to it and one of the most
interesting ones i think
is this one complete all non-optional
goals without building while the game is
paused and then the other optional goal
well is to reach all the goals by the
end of august year three
so the first optional goal is very
doable
but these are kind of finding each other
because it's very difficult to make the
first optional goal while
also doing everything by year three so
the challenge is basically try not to
pause the game ever
and build really quickly and be able to
get your guests in really quickly
um which is gonna be very hard and i'm
completely unsure if i can make this
because i don't build that much
unpaused i'm really used to building
unpaused
so i'm gonna try the challenge and see
how long it takes if it takes more than
three years then
so be it but i don't want to deliver an
ugly park just to be able to make these
challenges so it's going to be a bit of
a balancing act you know how much can
actually do in terms of scenery
to reach these goals but is it possible
to make this
optional goal yes or no that's the
question
so actually without further ado this
time
let's get to building and we can't build
like this because if we uh if we do wait
a second i'm gonna
try to play something down there we go
you get this notification that you
probably don't want to build while
you're paused if you want to reach all
of the goals
so yeah we're gonna click that away
and see if we can build an unpaused mode
the entire time
let's go so very quickly you'll probably
notice that i've been a little bit
cheeky-breaky here because um
usually i do actually play the game on
paused mode it's just that whenever i
play something
i unpause the game place it down as
quickly as i can
and pause the game again to try and lose
as
little time as i can trying to pick
colors and trying to find objects
which to be honest i almost always build
in past mode
so this was actually a much bigger
challenge than i expected because i take
so long to build things and well
one year in parkitect i believe is 50
minutes
right around that not entirely sure but
a month is 5 minutes
and it starts off in march and goes
until
the end of december so yeah basically 15
minutes if i'm not wrong i could be but
it's somewhere around that ballpark so
we don't have a lot of time here to
finish this park and
not to mention i also have the other
goals of actually reaching
the goals that you need to reach in the
scenario and also making sure that the
park runs
okay that i earn money and manage to
build new rides and make a profit
and of course also make it look decent
at the same time so
it's quite a challenge in that sense so
forgive me for pausing the game every
now and then to try and adjust things
so you'll you'll constantly see the game
move from past mode to unpaused mode
and kind of back and forth but every
single time i'm placing things
the game is unpassed that's the rule so
usually i pause just to pick a color
scheme or
see what objects i want to use or if i
want to go into the settings of
write you can do that in paused mode as
well so
you can place down the right and then
pause the game and see what color scheme
you want to give it
what price you're gonna ask for it stuff
like that
so you're always kind of playing with
the buttons here
and making sure that everything's
running correctly
and that everything's running while
you're building and standing still while
you're not building it's a
it's a really interesting race against
the clock because it's like
a race against the clock where you can
stop the clock but you also can't do
anything
and actually if i think about that right
now it's basically the super hot
but in in a theme park game i mean if
you don't move
the time is not running but if you're
doing anything the time is running i
guess that's how you should see it
so when it comes to what i'm actually
building i just quickly came up with a
little part
layout by pausing the game and looking
at the entrance section and trying to
come up with stuff to do
i really wanted to have a sort of
central plaza a place where i could put
shops and toilets all of that jazz while
hiding the backstage areas
and i figured the best option to do this
would be just to make one big building
incorporate different facades in that
try and mix the steampunk theme into it
a little bit of course
and just go from there so that's what
i'm working on here
it's going to be a mixture of different
looking buildings but in reality of
course it's all just a single building
with a single interior that just has the
function of
getting all of my all of my shops my
drinks and food in one place and making
sure that people are not going to
complain about that stuff
then next to that we have what is
probably the steam punkiest ride
in the in the game definitely one of the
most interesting rides
it's very new ride i believe last year
zamperla
came out with this model and it's one of
those flat rides which i think
in real life and in the game looks more
interesting than it is to ride because
in reality it's just
some simple ferris wheels on a rotating
pillar
but the way that it looks like they're
gonna bump into each other and it just
looks so complex and really fascinating
one of the coolest flat ride designs
that i've seen in a while
and i think some perla in real life can
be really proud of these things because
they're super cool
and it's not too often that you see a
completely new model of flat ride being
developed
and actually being purchased from parks
around the world
but this new model is really cool i i
approve and i'm very glad that it's in
the game
plus it looks very steampunk what with
the the colors of course on this one but
also just the general machinery and
the the outlandishness of the design i
think it fits very well into this
scenario
now as for the rest of the steampunk
approach to this park
i have to say i'm not actually going to
add too many pipes or
steam stuff or gears and things like
that
you guys know my opinion on steampunk i
am one of those people who's just like
you know it should be all about
victorian architecture and
about giving your machinery a purpose
and if there's no purpose to it then
don't just slap pipes and gears
everywhere that don't actually do
anything
which seems to be the the main way that
real steampunk enthusiasts
approach the genre and for this as well
i'm really just going with a color
scheme inspired by the buildings that
are already there
and kind of turn of the 19th century
style victorian architecture but
nothing else too ridiculous you're not
going to see big factories or anything
like that i think i could have maybe
gone there
with the volcano there's this really
cool roller coaster tycoon 3 coaster
called nero
by n7 aka mike sheets which
has a scenario where on a distant planet
there's a magma processing plant
and the magma goes through pipes and
huge machinery and stuff and it's some
kind of thermonuclear
not not thermal nuclear but a geothermal
power plant
something like that does does sound like
super cool
idea for steampunk stuff with actual
machinery but i just figured i wouldn't
have the time to work on something like
that if i can only build an
unpaused mode so i'm keeping it simple
here and just focusing on the bare
bone aesthetics and trying to bring out
the detail and steampunk feel with
colors rather than
details and machinery everywhere that's
not to say i'm not going to place a few
gears in pipes i definitely will
here and there but very sparingly
and maybe just there's some details and
accents here and there
now another ride which i think is very
steampunky is the the g-lock
which has those little planes
going upside down sideways on a big
rotating thing
i think in real life those things are
way more
comfortable and fun than they look i was
really scared of them before i'd been on
one of them but
honestly they're one of my favorite flat
rides really fun
um so always a good addition to the park
and it just kind of looks steampunky as
well so
figured it was good to have it in this
scenario too and here comes the first
coaster of the scenario and here i also
have to admit
you'll see me build the coaster here but
i'm not actually
coming up with the layout live the way i
did this was to
open an empty version of the park and
kind of mess
with the map and see what kind of
coaster layouts i could come up with
what kind of stuff you could build here
and once i had come up with the layout
that i was happy with
i moved into the park here unpaused the
game
and recreated the layout as quickly as i
could because i really can't afford to
lose any time so
i just wanted to make sure that whatever
work i can do up front
i want to do it up front and then we'll
see how much time is left for actual
money making
and micromanaging the actual scenario
goals
so this is a rmc well
monorail coaster which is still one of
my favorite coasters in this game
especially in scenario play they're so
much fun because you can build lift
hills and lsm launches
and they're also pretty cheap and
they're just really good at
building very well really good stat
coasters because
i think that's an especially important
thing when it comes to starting out with
the scenario you want some roller
coasters that are intense and have a
high
excitement rating so that people don't
get bored uh don't leave the park or
start
vandalizing stuff and these coasters are
just an amazing
first thrilling coaster i know we
already have the
launched spinning coaster in this
scenario but i'm still approaching it in
the same sense
this is probably the best coaster to
start out with
the best bang for the buck to make more
profit later down the line
and make sure that we can build more
coasters and rides as soon as possible
as well
now for the station and overall
surroundings of this coaster
i'm mostly just taking my inspiration
from the buildings that were already
there so
kind of building something very similar
i couldn't really come up with
many more built structures that i really
needed so instead i just added some
switchbacks to the queue and put some
different roof structures over that
with again the colors coming back from
the entrance area
as basically one main motif that brings
all of the architecture on this island
together
and then the station building itself is
kind of a mix
on a typical roller coaster station the
way that it starts out with the
gabled roof in the middle and then the
flat roofs on the side
is kind of a standard roller coaster
station building
it's not really too fancy and then to
make it fit into the scenario a bit more
and give it that steampunk vibe i'm just
adding some towers on the sides
which also helps to make it feel a
little bit less rectangular
because i often talk about the fact that
you want to avoid
rectangular buildings as much as
possible and sometimes it's just what
works out best so
you can't always avoid it and i think in
roller coaster stations especially
you often just end up with a perfect
rectangle and
towers domes and any kind of things that
you can put on the side
are always a nice way to avoid the
rectangleness
of a building and make it a bit more
interesting to look at
which i think in parkitect is especially
important because you're looking
at everything from above so just a
straight square building
is very quickly going to stick out and
seem like it's not really blending in
its environment too well so
i always want to be very careful with
that
this building's also pretty inspired by
the building of the
uh spinning coaster station which
honestly i do kind of prefer this one
i know i'm just taking a lot of
inspiration for it so well it's it's
basically a recurring motif at this
point
but this one has a little bit more
detail than the spinning coaster station
and the spire especially is a bit more
unique
and a combination of different pieces
that i hadn't used on the spinning
coaster
so i think it works out like this and
then another flat right that i wanted to
add in here
is the star shape which is not really my
favorite flat ride but uh for a while i
honestly wasn't sure if i was gonna put
any flat right here i just kept the area
open and figured that it could also just
work as a grassy area
but i have the money to build more flat
rides and i really need to make sure i
get as many people in as quickly as
possible so that later down the line
i don't have to put in too much effort
to reach the 800
guests because that is a very high cap
and it's going to be quite difficult to
reach that if i can only build an
unpassed mode so
i just figured the best way to go
forward was to constantly keep building
rides whenever i can
and this was just the easiest best space
for it at the time
now here comes the second coaster that
i'm gonna build and it's a flying
coaster
i was trying to figure out what i could
do with this hillside for a very long
time once again i'd opened up a separate
park file
and try to mess around with different
coaster types that are available
mostly i was looking at the inverting
wooden coaster because
like i said in the intro i really wanted
to use that thing because it's
new in the taste of adventure dlc i've
never built one of them in one of the
campaigns
and they're really fun to build i just
did i just couldn't come up with a
layout for it
um it was really difficult to work it
into the side of the terrain here
especially because the train is very
crammed you also have that path to worry
about
and it's kind of diagonal but not
completely diagonal as you can see it's
like
30 degrees or something which is very
difficult to work a layout into
eventually i just came up with this
layout for a flying coaster which i
think works much
better than any of my ideas for the
wooden coaster did
so yeah that's what we ended up with
it's just a terrain conforming flying
coaster that has a
pretty fun first drop i'd reckon down
into a pretzel loop over the water
and then you already start heading back
to the station
with one zero g roll and then a fly to
lie
element and a curve back into the final
break run
where you have one more light to fly
elements and into the brakes
so quite a few inversions actually for a
short layout
and also it's the kind of layout that
uses its energy perfectly i think
because once it
goes into those brakes it doesn't really
slam them it's just
very quietly and smoothly glides into
them
which is a i guess a roller coaster
that's very
environmentally friendly because we're
not using too much energy that gets
wasted
so you know it's pretty much perfect and
this is why i love terrain coasters as
well because it's the only time that you
can
make these coasters where the station is
pretty high compared to the rest of the
layout
so you can glide into the station with
not too much speed
it's always cool now the uh
very interesting thing about this layout
i guess is because the
the space is so crammed and we're on a
hillside here
i couldn't really figure out how to
place the station without going
underground so what i opted for
is the the last curve of the layout is
underground and then it comes into the
station which is above ground
so you get an interesting transition
there at the end
i think it's not the most realistic
thing but
if you are gonna tunnel i think you
should at least keep it as short as
possible to make it a bit more realistic
and i think this is
in the realm of possibility especially
for
the crazy kind of setting that this is i
know you're probably watching this and
thinking so why are you so concerned
about
this this park is literally built on an
active volcano
why are you worrying about coaster
realism i'm not sure there's just
a certain suspense of disbelief in my
head where i'll believe the crazy
scenarios that this game drops you in
but the roller coaster layouts have to
remain
realistic and within the realm of
possibility i
guess that's something that i had with
volvara as well where
i was going all in on trying to make the
layout as realistically
intimate as possible and people were
commenting like
this is this is a flying steampunk
island what are you even worrying about
but
somewhere in me there's the the theme
park nerd
who just wants all of the theme park
stuff to be realistic everything else
can be the craziest fantasy ever as long
as the the theme park stuff
kind of works out but yeah that's the
the flying coaster
and i open that as quickly as possible
get more guests into the park and make
more money
i'm very sorry but i'm not gonna provide
a real-time overview
because i couldn't really see the point
of it in this case because as soon as i
unpause the game
and try to show you around some stuff
that's easily a month or two lost
and that's just more than i can afford
with these tight goals
and my ambitions to to decorate
everything so
yeah we're just gonna sit this one out
until the end and see if i make the
goals in the
end and there's not gonna be any
feedback
in the middle of it so for me this is
also kind of all in because either i
make it
or i don't make it it's gonna be very
hard to walk back on some of the
decorations that i've made or
scenery that i've built i just have to
focus on the goal of getting to 800
people and
if it doesn't make it i'm not sure what
i'm gonna do
but yeah constantly building is the main
mentor here so
the next thing that i'm building is that
little flat ride
next to the coaster there which i think
also works because the coaster was
just seeming like something so away from
the rest of the park and didn't really
have anything else to do
it was just it just felt a little bit
too empty so
i figured i had to add that flat right
there and then after
a long time of thinking about where i
wanted to place more flat rides
i figured that the best place to put the
giant turbine was next to the
launch the spinning coaster and then the
same goes for the other drop tower
which god those things are so good
love it it's definitely my favorite type
of drop tower in the real world
and it's always fun to place one of
these things down in the game because
they're really fun to look at
because when they fall down at the end
where they where they break
the the the seats swing out because
the way it works if you don't know yet
is you rotate 90 degrees so that you're
looking straight down
then you fall down and just before you
hit the ground the seats swing up so
you get to you know level
height again i guess um you just have to
ride it
at some point in your life i'm not sure
how many examples there are
i know icarus in gronerlund in sweden is
what the in-game
ride is based on but i'm pretty sure
busch gardens temper
also has a very similar drop tower
but yeah more of the story is drop
towers that tilt you toward the ground
are
really cool and really fun and drop
towers in general are just
some of the last theme park rides that
actually scare me
i've been on so many big roller coasters
that roller coasters are just
never really that scary anymore i think
the last coaster i was really afraid of
was todo dompa
in fujikyo highland because it's just
that crazy insane of a launch
but drop towers still always scare me
just the height
is oof anyway i'm getting massively off
topic again turbine
next to it is also interesting it's a
flat ride that i think i don't place a
lot in my campaigns because it's really
unruly and it's just huge and it's hard
to fit it into any space
it also just looks a little bit weird
it's a typical fairground ride you don't
see them too much in theme parks so i
always feel a bit
weird for placing one of these in my
campaign maps
but i couldn't come up with much else to
place
and given the fact that i'm already
ruining the skyline with the drop tower
i figured i might as well just put the
turbine next to it and leave it at that
they are way more intense looking than
they actually are
i think boosters as they're often called
in real life
are just one of those crazy looking
fairground rides that
look like the scariest attraction but
are probably not
really the most intense interaction on
the fairground depending on what else is
on the fairground of course
but still fun ride and hopefully gonna
be a good aid
to reach the scenario goals and
from what i remember these are actually
some of the last
rides that i'm placing down in the
scenario here that you can see
um because as you can see in the bottom
left corner i'm getting closer and
closer to
august of year three and at the same
time i'm running out of money quickly so
yeah this is a pretty difficult
situation not to mention there's still
a lot of theming that i want to do i
left some theming stuff
just completely undone uh i wanted to
add more
terra painting for example around
certain areas of the park
thankfully you can still do terra
painting in paused mode so that was good
to know it's no building i guess
so it works but yeah i also wanted to
put more foliage and rock work
everywhere
to fit in a bit more with the buildings
that you already get at the start of the
scenario
so i'm placing that around all of the
different parts of the park as well
and then there are different path
decorations as well of course
certain spots that don't have lamps we
need benches everywhere
some planters some trash cans
all of that stuff which is not just
aesthetically
important but also really important to
make sure that people don't get too
tired because tired people are gonna
lower your park rating which
significantly impacts how many people
actually go to the park
and right now i need to get as high a
rating as possible
as quickly as possible not really to
reach the scenario goals because i think
i'm gonna reach that 85 percent
easily um but i want to go over that to
make sure that more people actually go
to the park
just to be safe so yeah that's what i'm
doing here at the end
and in the meantime i'm gonna be honest
and already reveal this
i've had many many different tries of
again and again redoing different things
that i did at the end game here because
time and time again i couldn't reach the
goals ahead of
august uh year three so there were so
many things i did differently every time
i
i built different coasters different
flat rides uh
food places um started hiding
an underground coaster at some point
which actually
to be fair it kind of worked but just
all of these different ideas and i kept
failing time and time again so
i got really upset at the end here but i
can already spoil
i think i have something good going but
i'm not entirely sure
yet so i'm gonna get out of this time
lapse and see really quickly
if we can make that goal and if so what
the park looks like
and how we can continue from here let's
go
so i just wanted to show this really
quickly the way i went about this was
just keeping many
different saves well actually just three
different saves at different states
so that i could always go back to an
older safe if i had to fix something in
hindsight
and then i just had to go through all of
these different maps time and time again
uh
many of which i saved but also many of
which i didn't save trying to reach the
goal
and well this is my last one where i
just added so close at the end because
ah after so many tries i'm almost at 800
guests and we're in august year three
but here's the thing you need to hold
the goal
of the the guest count that you need to
get for at least one month
so i am very curious to see if i
i'm going to somehow just barely make it
or
if i needed to hold that goal for one
month and i'm exactly one month late
and i should have really just been
aiming for july this whole time
honestly i don't know because i've never
had one of these
optional goals where um you have to
build an unpause mode because it's a new
thing
so let's actually just check and see how
we're doing on that front
and yeah there's a few seconds left
here we go um we have 800 guests in the
park
does that mean that we've completed the
optional
oh yes we get it oh that's awesome
okay i think i think we have it if i
managed to hold
three weeks just 800 people in the park
oh we're gonna make it oh that makes me
so happy
you know what in the meantime let's just
quickly go over the park there's still
some stuff that's unfinished but you
know at this point
forget about it everything is unfinished
art is always unfinished who cares
um this ride nobody wants to write
it's it's zero dollars oh yeah there's
something i have to explain
on my many tries of redoing this i found
out
there's one there's one really good
trick to get more people into the park
while making money at least temporarily
um the thing i did was i started asking
an entry price instead of
a price to ride coasters and rides so
everything is free in the park now and
you pay
20 euros as an entrance fee which
for a few months for the extra people
that i was getting
going from 600 to 800 in the last few
months made sure that i could still make
a profit
while at the same time making everybody
who was already in the park and gonna
leave shortly after
think that the prices were really good
so at this point
i have a decent prices rating it's
actually
not as good as i would hope but i think
a lot of that is just due to the fact
that people haven't left the park yet
because something to consider about
these ratings
is that they are based on people leaving
the park and the ratings that they leave
um but yeah all together pretty good
ratings
overall rating of 90 pretty happy with
that happiness is 100
uh many of the things like decoration
and stuff it's all
maxed out so that's really good um
so yeah functionally it all works i
think the only problem is once you start
running this park for a few more months
it's gonna lose a lot of money because
just making money off of your entrance
fee and not putting
effort into making money on anything
else is just not a very viable business
scheme in this game
it's somewhat doable and i've done it on
multiplayer as well but you just have to
start putting photo
uh the little photo track pieces on
every single ride and just ask a lot of
money for the photos
so it's it's not the best thing to do
really
but yeah for the time being i think it
works and
by the looks of it we'll make the
scenario with this trick so
yeah that's that's one of the last
things that pushed me over the edge
another thing
is surprise surprise this build also has
a sneaky underground roller coaster
it doesn't have a very good layout but
it does have a layout that results in
pretty good stats and it's absolutely
instrumental in
reaching the the goal in this scenario
just
keep it hidden for people nobody think
about the fact that there is a little
secret
underground passage here with a ride why
am i still researching stuff
we can turn that off um but yeah
honestly i i wish i didn't have to do it
but i just didn't see myself
reaching the goals in a legit way i know
this kind of feels like cheating
but you know gameplay-wise everything's
fair and square and i only built an
unpaused mode so um yeah
here we are let's actually do a quick
pov of the flying coaster here now that
it's
doing its thing anyway so here we fly
over the path
into that pretzel loop this flying coast
is actually surprisingly small the only
reason that it can do these elements is
because it's built over the water here
so it's a lot lower than the station and
the lift hill are at
so we go through that zero g roll and
then kind of a half cork screw that
support doesn't look very nice but it is
what it is i guess
and final light to fly elements and as
you can see it really glides into those
brakes
i love that but yeah this is also a very
efficient coaster with a very short lift
hill
that doesn't have any supports i should
have probably custom supported this
thing
oh well i i didn't mention it nobody has
seen the
the weird supportness quirks i would
have put supports here if i still had
the time but
trust me i just came out of building
that wooden coaster underground and
fixing some other stuff and
building new stalls and trying to
scramble this thing together
gameplay-wise
now before we reach those goals let's do
a quick pov
of the monorail coaster as well which is
really long trains just to make sure
that this thing can actually earn some
money
and actually work through its q line as
well
because god knows these things are not
the most efficient rides normally
so yeah we have that kind of typical rmc
turn around there
into um i forgot again
well dive loop yeah that's a dive loop
uh into a corkscrew
and we go down over the path here and we
have an immelman
there we go i'm starting to remember
things thanks for everybody who left
comments on
the last episode by the way meanwhile we
reached the goals that's very nice
and the layout is just snaking its way
with some finer helixes and curves
back into the station and that's a full
circuit
uh the the very slow lift hill is
just to make sure that it doesn't stop
on the lift hill but i think the timing
is
just right when it comes to the block
brakes here and not to mention
this thing is a pretty good money maker
well if it is money making
we are going to go bankrupt but nobody
cares i reached the goal of the scenario
they can uh suck it for all i care
i think we're done here i think we're
good to go so
i think i'm pretty happy with the
scenario oh yeah a few more things that
are interesting to show off i think
we have this little nice flat ride area
with some crazy
intense flat rides i don't think i ever
showed a pov
of one of the skyfall rides i'm very
sorry if i actually did
can i okay we're just gonna have to
look at it from a distance i'm gonna
have to remove that bankruptcy thing
so yeah these things are really cool
because once you go up here
it starts rotating you 90 degrees and
you start looking down
come on are we here
okay i guess it's still going to take a
while but yeah you can you can enjoy the
view of the sea
really beautiful really cool very
intense very
thrilling this is the exact reason i
still think these things are scary
there we go at 90 degrees and then you
fall down and
whoop you swing out it's really fun
uh really scary just absolutely amazing
drop rights
and then of course we have this crazy
flat ride now that i think about it
most of the flat rides in this park are
very intense
besides those that we've already seen we
have the drop tower of course
topspin which is very intense this thing
which is of course very intense and also
this thing which is very intense
i think this is by far the lamest flat
ride
in the park and i mean that just in
terms of how intense it is
other than that it's super cool it
really has that steampunk design
actually with the gears and
of course the colors and you choose
those yourself partly but
the colors that it starts out with as
well are a bit more bright but could
still fit
in the same kind of theme i think but
yeah i just want to see this
this thing move because it's so
interesting and
as you're gonna see it doesn't really do
too much doesn't really make you go
upside down or anything like that
they're really just rotating ferris
wheels that move a bit quicker than a
normal ferris wheel does it's a little
bit like one of those moving carpet
rides
but the way that they all just
seamlessly blend
into each other it just i don't know to
my brain
it looks really weird it's very
confusing i understand how it works but
my brain just doesn't want to get it it
just
looks like it shouldn't be able to do
that very cool rides
really cool design and big ups to
zamperla for coming up with those things
here by the way this building piece is
unfinished
i put a temporary fence here which is a
very messy way of
fixing stuff but you know what i think
that's all part of the scenario
and you know real life parks also have
some unfinished bits here and there
that's just how things go so all
together
i'm pretty happy with this scenario and
for one
where i've built everything in unpaused
mode i'm glad that i've actually been
able to make the uh
non-optional goals as well and at the
same time put down a park
that's decent looking so
let's just go back to the main menu and
see what's next
i do have to say i don't think i'm going
to try to go for the
non well the optional goals in all of
the scenarios because that stuff is
really hard
alright so there's our trophy and let's
see where
our adventure goes next a new island of
course
and it's going to be ah candyland
awesome all right so the next episode is
going to be candyland
as you can see we have a whole slew of
optional goals that i'm probably
not going to reach this time around but
maybe i will
we'll see anyway i hope you guys enjoyed
this video
and i hope to see in the next one bye